one of the all-time greats his solo
album tenderness is gonna be released on
May 31st a day after a North American
tour of his kicks off in Philadelphia
the single chip away can be already
heard Duff online.com is how you can
pre-order a chance to catch a special
Grammy Museum performance that will be
next week Duff McKagan good to see you
sir good to be here how you been good
seeing you too ray you bet you got your
Mariners hat on well I mean you already
go opening day is here correct
I'm ready ish to go well I have the best
record in baseball right we do no yeah
but good yeah we're going 162 I was
gonna make a shirt at least saying
two-and-oh for today
yeah it's been a tough it's been a tough
road being a Mariners fan you know it's
really been tough we had something go
it's kind of like my fantasy football
league yeah in our league yes like I was
I had something going team McKagan was
doing very was killing it
yeah and then suddenly just the wheels
came off there was a couple bad boos and
this is one of your best years you've
had though wasn't yeah my Jess chick
yeah I've got a guy my new guy you've
got a guy I got a guy it was it was my
nephew but he's busy graduated USC and
then he he went off to work in Denver he
just got busy well no disrespect you
know if you would I don't think he was
doing a very good job
he's busy okay yeah I mean he's he's
like a he's a Rain Man when it comes to
like stats all of that stuff right you
know it has been since he was like 13
years old but he just got busy and and
last summer I guess would have been when
Pearl Jam was playing the home shows in
Seattle my wife Susan and I went to one
of the shows and we're side stage Mike
McCready is my good buddy
and this friend of his Jeri is the head
of security for the anti angels Jerry
lives in Orange County he's a cop down
there yeah and Jerry came up to me
during the show the Pearl Jam showing it
goes your your team your fantasy team
sucks
we gotta change that you know your team
always falls apart you draft good you
always drive too many Seahawks you got
we got to stop that you know Kay and I'm
and I you know I said well I've been on
the road like I tour I pay attention to
the team but you know that's at the
waiver I don't understand the waiver
wire all that stuff I just drop my guys
and and you switch him out on by Bleek's
and I'm off to the races but he said you
can't I'm coming out I'm gonna be your
partner he came to the draft with me at
Jerry Cantrell's house yes that's what
Chris Broughton was there representing
uh representing our team I don't know if
you met my Jimmy Jerry the Anaheim cop
knows what he's doing for fantasy
football I mean he was talking smack at
the I'm like wow everyone talked so much
trash at this draft I got it and then
Jeff Garlin shows up with no no computer
nothing
garland played in the finals we played
garland in the finals this year and his
name is team's name is unmentionables
los grandmas and then he mentions yeah
yeah the body part they have normally a
grandma doesn't have I was at I went to
a bowling birthday party a few weeks ago
and I get his pact and I walk in and
there's Jeff Garlin without a shirt on
how's it go gives me a big hug fantastic
team did very well this year so that's
good we did well yeah my partner Jerry
he apologized and he said I got busy and
didn't I made a couple bad moves he I
think he has like ten different fantasy
teams but at least I made it into some
uncharted territory right for me right
exactly
Oh season well you know Jerry Cantrell
oh by the way Duff McKagan here on to
Rich Eisen so Jerry has a weakness okay
and that is he is the he's just a
complainer when his team is losing it's
true there's actually been wine and
essentially like give up and just [ __ ]
and moan and just complain
about how might steams not performing
like so are you are you forfeiting this
week no I'm not
right and then his team wins and it's
just it's just annoying that just though
he's the complainer and Mona what has
changed but you're right what so the
seasons before you can see my team was
out it's like hey man we've been bros
for a long time okay
will you trade me this guy side text you
know and this year he started my team
was doing too good
it was like a couple he texted me a
couple of things I like Jerry Nam I like
my team and so yeah he will get he's
very competitive so you're he was using
your new Duff McKagan in his
relationship to say help me out on
fantasy since we go way back in your
team go that T but am I getting him in
trouble right now yeah you would that's
the worst that's the what I mean in
terms of a flagrant violation of fantasy
is that yeah well I didn't mean to throw
him under the bus because it really
didn't go down like this okay cuz I'll
throw them under the bus I don't mind
because but Jerry is very competitive
do you anything you not just the fantasy
league yeah that's a competitive guy
like in terms of how many people show
okay dice whatever it is he's very
competitive but it's made him an amazing
guitar player in song and I'm sure this
comes in handy yes I know what is it
about Seattle that everybody is so
talented in music I mean what is it
about that city that so many people come
out of that city and are so successful
and all root for the Seahawks right it's
when you're from Seattle you stay
Seattle for sure like I I didn't move
down to LA in the 80s and suddenly start
rooting for the Dodger Lakers I don't
even have a basketball team anymore but
I'm still Sonic's fan okay and the
Lakers are still the enemy right that's
enemy number one if you're a song expand
so there's still the enemy and I don't
have a team that's how that's what see
how it does to you you're right your
Seahawks fan your Mariners fan no matter
what but did the music
thing I I really attribute the talent to
nut one thing was it rains a lot there
and it does so everybody goes to their
garage in the basement and plays and
often times especially in the early 80s
and mid 80s every but every band would
share the same rehearsal place or two
places so you shared ideas there was
when I moved to LA in 84 I saw there was
competition between bands bands would
try to sabotage other bands that just
doesn't happen in Seattle like bands
will try to help each other out
okay I'll Gare and and therefore you
shared like riffs you would share
guitars so who did you share with do you
have a good story or who shared with you
or you you with them or something I mean
well I mean a lot of the earlier bands
before you know Allison chains and
Soundgarden I mean I knew Kim tale from
sound before I left and Chris Cornell of
course we're all the same age Chris and
I went at the same schools alternative
school and stuff and we were in st. punk
rock scene so I don't know who did I
share what that's a good question I only
try to ask those Duff McKagan
you know I mean I try my best yeah just
and so I think I noticed a big
difference when I moved here that the
competition no sharing of ideas no
sharing of like hey I got this other
than this new riff on guitar I'll show
it to you there was none of that
it was just hide and and try to you know
bands would try to sabotage our gear
good luck with that well you know we
were trying to like flyer where they
would fly over our flyers you know you
just get done putting up flyers all
around Hollywood and you'd come back the
next day and somebody would fly over you
that didn't last long with other bands
we were we were if it was gonna be
competition if you want to play it like
that yeah we were the wrong band to kind
of do that why is that and 85-86 why is
that um we weren't here to play around
you know let it play around you ought to
play kids games Axl is insane
oh yeah he didn't take it
and easily you know especially you know
I was like afraid of no man you know but
but all of us were kind of we'd move
from other towns but we'd been in bands
where we were from we didn't come out
here for to play high school games so
Duff McKagan here on the Rich Eisen show
and so before we get to your upcoming
project yeah I'm slash says there's a
talk of an upcoming album from Guns and
Roses you've confirmed it
do you got any update on that I do have
an update on it I just I must say things
are very positive in in that world and I
understand why like I did say something
about it in an interview people are
super interested in that mmm and I
understand why I do like the mystique
factor of the band and I shall keep it
there but things are positive things are
positive there's a very is there any
details you can give on why they were so
positive just saying they're positive
it's a good detail I think I things are
great you know we had a wonderful
amazing to a half year to her we just
did and it ended on such a high note and
it was overwhelming how many people came
to see those shows we played 159 shows
Wow you know after the Troubadour we
played The Troubadour April 1st 2016
mmm was it an axle broke his foot that
foot like third song in and I thought
well you know we've got this we got this
one show under about we did this thing
and and he wanted to continue on like
this isn't gonna stop me we played a
bunch of shows with him in a cast in the
chair and we just went through so many
kind of revelations of things and and
ended that on a high note and that's
where we're still at and then now we've
got tenderness coming out on the first
of May and then you are going on a tour
starting in Philadelphia on yeah 30th
what's this special Grammy Museum
performance coming out on the 4th what
are you doing there
yeah it's a it's a Grammy Museum does
these cool little performance sings
question answer right around the owner
from Staples downtown Los Angeles yeah
I've been to a couple of them I did one
for my first book it so easy book mm-hmm
that I wrote in 2010 or 11 whenever that
was
but shooter and I and Aubrey who's the
fiddle player backup singer for the band
amazing musician we're gonna do the
performance there and a QA I think it's
sold out so if there's tickets available
through you that's a cool thing
Duff online done you know you'll get a
get a sneak peek Thank You of what this
thing is not so awesome yeah this is
this end and and then what why
tenderness why that okay
snapshot of that is I read a lot of
history I a lot and I'll read like four
different versions of the same story say
Normandy
I'll read the the Stephen Ambrose
version of Band of Brothers I'll read
that there's a book by a journalist who
was entrenched with the German guys who
were kids who were there at Normandy all
the way back to Berlin you'll read it
from so I'll read stories from three or
four different sides I tried to and I
not just World War two history but Civil
War history polar exploration history
mountain climbing history you name it
I've read hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of books and I'm just into it
I'm an armchair historian mm-hmm
I have the daughters of girls 18 and 21
I have a successful marriage I was a
calling a columnist for ESPN and for
Seattle Weekly for five years that's a
weekly column during that time I found
myself becoming an observational list
because you have to write a column every
week right so you got up what am I gonna
write my column on and you kind of like
take stock of things during this tour in
arguably one of them more
interesting times in our history the two
and a half years we were on tour world
world history American history very
interesting time if you watch the news
in America this three cable news
networks a lot of screaming a lot of if
you go on Twitter at the same time you
wake up and go on Twitter
no it's please and then you watch some
more all right so what I found we went
on this tour and I would go to places
where that news wasn't available and I
don't usually read Twitter I'll post
something from like soundcheck mmm and
not look suddenly the the quality I
would get out and I go out like you just
went to Italy I got up when I go to
Italy or it places I go to museums or
I'll go to historical sites I want to
see there's a lot of ruins there that I
love but I do that worldwide I go on any
and when you go out and see these things
you talk to people right and you don't
feel so insular and you don't feel like
you're inundated with so much stuff
right exactly so I came back to on
American tour sites I just wouldn't
watch news and go on Twitter I would go
out and see stuff right got a little
bighorn ER or Monticello or whatever I'd
go and I've talked to people and I do
this constantly and I've my
observational bit of this was I didn't
see this divide that was being preached
and yelled about on TV and on Twitter I
just didn't see it and it's a lot less
in the America that that I know is the
one like that came together after nine
9/11 you know nobody asked who you voted
for we just came together and had each
other's backs after the hurricane and in
Houston in recent let's just go to
recent sure we came together people came
together I think a JJ Watt thing that he
put out you know and raised all that
money in the New Orleans and the fires
here in California people come together
and help out and that's the America that
I choose to to see and we're not all of
us so different at all and I wrote
little vignettes about my observations
traveling the world not just America
there's things going on all over the
world that are just unusual and reading
so much history as I do I know things
past
there's cycles and this has happened in
America before Britain stuff has
happened there kind of like this before
not in recent history but it's happened
there so I was gonna write a book about
that not about the guns roses tour like
what's going on with the band I said
everything else everything else and so
you wrote tenders and instead tenderness
I I started writing these little
vignettes so we're gonna become chapters
for a book but instead I had a kusik
guitar with me on on the road and I
started writing songs and it's sort of a
concept record if you will but it's
maybe more about healing and finger
pointing that's it that comes out on the
31st of May which you know I
it makes it difficult to make this turn
but I'm gonna do it anyway Jerry
Cantrell refuses to take a bet of mine
this is easy to I mean you know you just
talked about coming together and being
as one and you know I still have to
bring it up I'm wondering would you take
this bet hmm that he refuses to do he
did take it once and unfortunately he
beat me in the finals where I dressed up
as I remember this day of he there it is
up on the screen good lord
I think tough I mean it's you owned it
that's the thing you gotta own something
like Marshall shake it is that day yeah
okay you did Oh hundred percent so I
wanted to make it the same wager with
Jerry again and he said no and then that
is is that I'll figure out whatever I
have to do if your team beats mine in
fantasy next year but if my team beats
yours
you have to sing let it go from frozen
acoustically on this show by myself yes
sir that's the bet that's the bet and
Jerry well does some like my girls are
too old for frozen but you're a euro
euro a musician of note Duff McKagan I
think you could learn it so if I lose to
you in the finals if I make it to say
I'm talking to me I said the fight like
you wouldn't want to do it these goes
that's a final spread rich it's a finals
bet say yes let's write yes in the
finals if we play each other in the
finals you got this stuff that we beat
you you would have to come on the Rich
Eisen show and sing let it go from
frozen so you so I if I make it the
final set that's just that's amazing
in itself great here okay yeah you and
Jerry the cop from the up from you're
watching right now yeah we got a win
next year are you accepting this and I
got what I got I gotta figure out what
you gotta do well dress should I do you
know one sorry did the metal guy no
that's okay but what size is axel you
know like do we have are we the same
size no no it's gotta be something more
I mean says performance like something
that's way out of my comfort so Kay you
already did to dress up as somebody yeah
there's got to be something else okay
I'm open for it expose you just as much
as frozen expose whatever that is I
accept Riley accept as long as you
accept my end right now he's gotta be
your roadie yeah but I mean I wouldn't
last two seconds but that's okay that's
alright but that he would actually be
enjoyable we got lost the time to figure
this yeah well okay we'll figure it out
sure Rich Eisen I'll take your bed Jerry
anyway oh by the way it's a great song
but it's a beautiful I've heard it sung
it's a beautiful song about love you
know what happens when your kids get
past that age then you've missed
all the stuffed frozen yes no not me
help you Duff is what it say you're
right in the midst of it what's your
five through ten year old that's right
I'm in the Dom in the thick of it but in
your at least you're doing something
Cantrell refused to do well done does
gonna do it he doesn't he refused him he
refused but it's okay maybe I'll do it
with Kentrell oh do it okay now we're
getting what if I beat Cantrell on the
way to beating Duff McKagan what if we
do pardon me I'm sorry Chris thanks for
coming on Duff thanks for having me
let's don't be a stranger at DAF McKagan
on twitter official Duff McKagan on
Instagram Duff online.com is how you can
get all the information you need North
American tour kicks off on May 30th I
love the concept of time to bond tender
yeah thank you yeah it's awesome I think
it's for all of us you know that's what
that was my intention and I'll end on
this note
Mariners 162 now yeah and seok's not
sixteen you know right next yeah yeah of
course yeah and everything's gonna be
great for you except the frozen song
which is gonna be going out with the
Final Fantasy it'll be great for the
rest of us like maybe with not very many
clothes on the show
Duff there's a couple questions we were
gonna ask I didn't get to hear is it
true that the creators of the Simpson
asked you permission to name the
fictional beer and the series Duff after
you is that a true story well it is a
true story but but this is like 1988 or
something and this is before branding
became I don't know what branding was in
it we got a call to my management office
my manager called me and said some like
there was no adult cartoons really
doesn't know so I thought it was like a
we just started a college art project
and they want to use your name as the
beer because I was known as deaf the
king of beers at that point that the mtv
live in new york at the at the urban
Plaza just aired an actual introduce me
it stuff the king of beers I had like
this championship belt a Budweiser belts
and so we did we thought it was a cute
like pop culture you know college art
project but it became this thing yeah
well it's now the longest-running
television series in the history of the
medium there you go I should ask for a
nickel check each time yeah buddy you
know I didn't know I don't I don't know
why I wrote it in my book yeah at my
first book I didn't know it's gonna be
this huge revelation it became one of
those things like in either your book
that becomes like the hot topic to talk
about and I just thought it was like a
foregone conclusion that everybody knew
that yeah but some beer is Duff McKagan
that's all figure say no I met one of
the cut at the creators I was in line at
Starbucks in Encino yeah a few years ago
and you know they asked your name and I
put depth and they my coffee was done
they said Duff and I grab my coffee and
it's this this nice woman came up to me
she goes my husband created a show that
he has a character named Duff and all of
a sudden she looks me you guys should
get together and talk and I I think I
gave her my mic my email or something
like okay nothing I think she got home
we don't want to talk to him but I held
nothing against them the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience